hello everyone
and uh welcome to our free webinar
we're going to be starting here in just
a minute so hopefully
everyone can join on time
good morning and welcome to this free
webinar
in this session we will discuss
our upcoming training program called
omix logic data science
and the online research opportunities
for students faculty and industry
professionals
that you can leverage to apply
bioinformatics to complex and
fascinating data sets
demonstrating your data science skills
and learning about biology
different diseases and the treatments
that are coming out
from the data that we have about these
biological conditions
so i'm excited to welcome you to this
free webinar again we're just going to
start
here in just a couple more minutes as
everybody is just joining right now
and i'm looking forward to also
interacting with you and getting to
know all of you hoping that you will
attend full program that will start
on august 3rd
now i know that for some of you this is
not morning this is actually evening
so we're here in new orleans and it's
morning time for us and this recording
of this webinar is also going to be
available
for future reference
okay so for those joining us for the
first time my name is ilya brodsky i'm
the co-founder and ceo of pine biotech
our vision here at pine biotech is to
enhance human health and well-being
by enabling biological research and
discovery with relevant data
solutions and expert support our mission
is to simplify
bioinformatics and advanced research
through our modular and intuitive multi
armaments analysis platform
powered by human experience and
artificial intelligence
you can read more about us at
pine-biotech.com
but what our company does is we offer
training research support
and big data analytics tools designed
for research and biomedical discovery
our mission is to support cutting-edge
research projects and solve
big data challenges by developing
innovative solutions
that are easy to use and to provide
training to use them effectively
and help scientists arrive at sound and
reproducible results
am honored to have been working with a
team that collectively have
an amazing amount of experience in this
area including the other co-founders of
the company dr
alfred tauber and dr lena brodsky
they come from a medical background with
expertise in oncology immunology and
biochemistry of inflammation as long as
as well as bioinformatics and
biostatistics
dr tauber has a long-standing
recognition for his generous support of
many international projects and research
activities
and one of these projects is the
establishment of the tower
bioinformatics research center
which is developing the core technology
upon which our platform is based
dr lena brodsky is the director of the
talbot bioinformatics research center
and is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
has numerous publications on
bioinformatics algorithms
and has developed a number of different
novel algorithmic approaches
that are specific to different types of
biomedical data analysis
these have been widely used in basic and
translational research in biotechnology
pharmaceutical r d
agriculture and basic research well
what we will discuss today is also a
result of hard work
by some of the people mentioned here on
the left julia pinoff who is an expert
bioinformatician has helped prepare many
of the materials we will use
avi ttyevsky who is a computer scientist
and leads the development of the tbionfo
platform that we will leverage
mohit mazumder who is in charge of
business development for pine biotech
joshua mckindle who maintains the
educational web portal
we will leverage and beeps abysswas our
online community
manager and support specialist so i'm
sure that many of you already had the
chance to interact with already
of course there are many more on our
team and that i simply do not have time
to mention specifically in this short
period of time but it's really a great
team
that is all committed to making
bioinformatics more accessible
over the past several years we have
conducted
a number of programs for thousands of
participants
both online and at a variety of
university campuses around the world
we have been working with faculty
researchers and students
to build a collection of essential
bioinformatics training modules
that cover the important omics data
types methods of analysis
and illustrations that demonstrate
applications of bioinformatics to
various life science domains
so the online omixlogic programs are
built on this foundation
as in all of our programs this upcoming
omics logic data science program
will give you access to all of our
online training resources
and include special daily meetings for
one and a half hours
each day that will provide a hands-on
experience
and interactive learning sessions that
are much different from
what you typically get from online
courses
the program is a combination of
interactive sessions
asynchronous coursework coding
assignments
and support from our team that will be
available to assist you
and help you overcome any technical
challenges
that you might face over the course of
the program
you will get a chance to build a
personal profile
completing online coursework answering
quiz questions
completing assignments and gaining new
badges to demonstrate your
accomplishment
the point system is based on detailed
data that reflects participant activity
including time spent in modules and
quizzes different grades
practical analysis evaluation and points
for completing coding challenges
upon completing the program requirements
of participation and minimum course
completion you receive a certificate of
participation that you can always use on
your resume
linking to a profile that also shows all
of your achievements over time
for those that decide to continue and
work on a project of their own
for the duration of the program you will
also gain personal feedback from an
expert
in the field that we will match you with
when the project is complete you will
receive
a special certificate of excellence
that's why our previous program
participants rank
the onyx logic programs at the top based
on program
interactivity personal feedback support
and the quality of projects that you
will be able to achieve
leveraging the resources that are made
available as a part of this program
so let me briefly speak about the omics
logic data science program
what is it all about and what are you
going to expect to get out of this
program
let's start from the beginning what is
data science and how is it related
to biomedical or omics data the truth is
is that data science is a recent term
that is used to represent
a variety of different things statistics
computer science and a variety of
different applications
in different domains for example data
science could mean
preparing data for analysis when you
extract data from financial markets
it could also mean that you're analyzing
advertising revenue
and different audiences or preparing
sentiment analysis when you analyze
social media data when we talk about
biomedical data that is the domain
knowledge that you must have
to be able to apply effectively computer
science and statistics principles
to extract knowledge or inference
from the data that you have access to so
when we talk about
data science in the context of biology
that is typically or traditionally has
been referred to
as bioinformatics bioinformatics in
itself
is also a diverse field bioinformatics
covers
collection of data annotation of data
access to different types of data
as well as the tools to analyze
visualize
and interpret this data so we are going
to focus on this program
specifically on the omixlogic data
science portion
of bioinformatics so we'll talk about
briefly different
types of omics data formats and
challenges associated with some of the
new types of data that are
being that are becoming more and more
widely accessible
we're going to talk about how to use
exploratory data analysis
to prepare the data appropriately for
the different types of analysis for
downstream
analysis and how you can use different
types of statistical properties of the
data
to understand whether you can you have
to
normalize it and remove outliers
we'll also cover a topic that has been
becoming more and more popular and
interesting in a variety of domains
called machine learning now machine
learning is
a term that has been around since the
1950s
and has really transformed our ability
to deal with
big data surprisingly in biomedical data
or biological data
new technologies called high throughput
technologies have really
made big data problems central to
discovery
and application of data analysis in this
field
so we'll talk about machine learning the
different types of machine learning
and discuss the specific methods of
analysis
and interpretation because ultimately
the goal of this program
is to help link the raw sources of data
to the different tools and methods of
processing
analysis visualization and to help make
scientific sound and logical
interpretation
of the outputs from these different
methods so in the program
we have combined a number of interactive
sessions
that we will conduct for an hour and a
half
each day over the course of two weeks
a total of 10 different sessions where
you will be able to ask questions
we will introduce topics and we will
also guide you
to complete specific self-guided study
materials that will expand on the topics
that we don't have time to cover in
these interactive sessions
in the self-guided study materials we
will suggest some study materials for
you to complete before our next session
but we realized that the time to go in
depth into each step of analysis will
take
a lot of time so we will offer you
additional time at the end of the
program to complete some of these
resources
on your own self-guided time we'll also
do practical assignments these include
big data processing pipelines as well as
coding assignments
in both r and python so let me briefly
speak about some of these in greater
detail
an important application in biomedical
research for machine learning has been
in both clinical
and pharma and biotech as well as the
practical
research or the basic research
applications and so we'll talk about
these
starting from the general logic which
helps us understand the objective
the problem that is there for us to
solve
and then we'll talk about examples where
some of the machine learning tools and
data science principles
have been used effectively to find
interesting
insights about these problems that touch
every one of us
now it's important to understand these
challenges and problems
in industry and both research because
they apply
to anyone involved in the life science
research and application and when i mean
everyone
i mean those that are in the lab so lab
technicians that are
generating more and hopefully better
data that need to understand how this
data is utilized
i'm talking about those that are going
to develop new
data analysis tools and integration
which is a huge challenge right now in
biomedical research
as well as those that have to make
decisions based on some of the
tools models and data sets that are
available
so we're really talking about
bioinformatics
or biology as a data science that is
applicable
for all of these categories of
participants
let me talk about some of these
different topics in greater detail
so omix logic data science program
will start on august 3rd next week
on monday each day for an hour and a
half we will meet
together and we will discuss a variety
of topics
these are divided into two different
weeks the first week is going to be
dedicated to data preparation
understanding the different types of
omics data and their properties
these are associated with big data
challenges and opportunities
and they require effective cleaning
loading and processing of data
you also have to know how to explore
this data quickly using statistical
assessment
to understand outliers and normalize
your data preparing it
for the specific types of analysis that
we will cover in week two
in the week two we will talk about
different types of
machine learning and artificial
intelligence now it's a fascinating
topic that we'll touch on a little bit
in in detail today but we will talk
about it
from first a high level where we have
the two different categories of
supervised and supervised
machine learning we'll talk about the
models that are available
and how to train and fine-tune those
models
and we'll also talk about evaluation of
their accuracy
and how to make them applicable to a
more
general application or project
and we'll also talk about production
quality so when we talk about production
we're actually trying to solve real
challenges so we'll provide a few
examples
of how they are applied in the real
world
so when we talk about data processing
we're really talking about
different data formats that are really
changing as a result of a variety of
different high throughput omix
technologies
and they require a combination of
methods that are
combined together in a sequential way
forming what we call bioinformatics
pipelines
for example when we talk about different
types of omix technologies we're really
talking about
technologies like next generation
sequencing mass spectroscopy
different types of structural data and
each type of these data sets
could be fine-tuned to study different
topics for example we can study
variation at the genomic level mutations
we can study methylation
which will allow us to understand the
structure of chromatin and how it
changes
gene expression we can also talk about
proteins that are being extra expressed
and how they interact with each other
protein protein interactions
or even study the microbiome the variety
of
small microorganisms that
can shape together as a community our
ability to
process different types of foods or
react to different types of
environmental
stresses and challenges so we'll spend
the first part of the program
talking about these different types of
data and how they are processed how do
we turn them from
raw data a raw direct output from that
machine from the technical instrument
that produces raw data
into what we call structured data
after that we will introduce our big
data analysis multi-omics platform that
you will have
access to where you can analyze these
data sets
without having to have extreme high
performance computing resources on your
own
typically in a production environment
you would design
a pipeline and then apply this pipeline
to a variety of different data sets
utilizing a predefined space and
computational resources so that's
exactly what this platform provides
now you will also discover that as you
learn about these pipelines you actually
get to understand the logic of this
analysis and the logic of this analysis
is reinforced by color-coded maps
explained methods with references to
in-depth review in research articles a
variety of
input and output formats that allow us
to both visualize the data
and understand how this data is
associated with different phenotypes
and also is a guided process so it
eliminates
a lot of the mistakes that people
typically make
when they first start building those
pipelines
now as a result you also get to
understand what reproducible workflows
really
are so that you can take that further
and apply that logic to a variety of
problems that you will face in the
future
now behind each one of these methods is
a piece of code
a script and so as we look at these
different steps
we'll take a few of those examples and
dig deeper to understand
how does it actually work and what
stands behind
each one of these buttons then we'll
also talk
about data visualization and
normalization so an
important part of working with these
types of data sets is understanding
what they represent and when we say what
they represent because we have
so many different indicators for example
over 20 000
genes or over 3.2 billion base pairs in
the human genome
we really have to understand what they
speak about
what they can tell us about a variety of
different conditions
and so when we do that we have a number
of coding challenges that will help us
understand
how you can apply best practices
in both r and python to visualize this
data
and make that visualization more
impactful
for example in our practice example
examples you will see how you can select
an example of a specific type of a
visualization
learn about the code and as you learn
about the code and the outputs
you then get access to try yourself how
to
go through this code change some of the
settings
and in a step-by-step fashion develop an
understanding
of what the code does at each part and
then
how does it produce some of these
visualizations so by changing some of
this code
and by practicing in different
environments for example
in r and in python you will really start
understanding
what are the benefits of using some of
this technology
so we'll also see how in the future as
you
use some of these methods you will be
able to work with some of this
information
inside not only on our onyx logic code
platform
but also as you download the code that
you've produced on the platform
and then modifying it on your computer
so that you can also take that away
from the program we'll also show
how some of these apply in biomedical
research so we'll talk about different
examples that you can start playing
around with different types of data
for example for cancer diagnostics and
an
understanding of cancer biology or an
understanding of single
cell data and tissue composition how you
can also study the microbiome
and different types of infections at the
genomic level
or at the diversity level so ultimately
when we say
projects and example data sets we
actually mean taking publications from
cutting-edge research articles and
journals
and breaking those down in terms of what
the authors did
where did they find the data what type
of data it was what kinds of methods
they applied to that data
and ultimately what is the use the
practical application
of the type of analysis that they
performed
when we move on to week two we'll start
talking about
data mining and classification
so first about data mining when we have
big data sets it's important to
understand how these big data sets
can be very complex once they are
taken as a whole and we have specific
methods that can allow us to identify
patterns in these complex data sets by
using
data dimensionality reduction and
clustering
so we'll talk about how when you have
your source data
right and the source data is unlabeled
you just have a number of samples
you can apply a variety of different
algorithms to really understand
what is in the data in terms of patterns
and these
algorithms give us novel information so
this new information that we get out of
these
algorithms is the association or
identification
which group they belong to so we'll talk
about a variety of these
algorithms including different types of
clustering
principle component analysis and other
types of dimensionality reduction
techniques that
apply to different types of data
differently these will be both a high
level
overview that will provide with clear
explanation of
why and when and how to use some of
these methods and for what purpose like
pca for data exploration visualization
and some of the considerations that you
need to have and that really make a
difference
when you try to apply these different
types of data sets
when we talk about clustering we'll
actually talk about the specific
process of going from bottom up or
top-down approaches how do they differ
what kind of information do they provide
and how can we apply them to a variety
of these different problems
we'll start from an intuitive
user-friendly interface well
all you have to do is upload your data
start your process
and then understand what are the
specific
settings of each algorithm so when we
talk about these specific
settings we can try to apply different
types of settings
change those parameters and see what are
the outputs
but then we also have to learn about the
specific linkages
distances expected counts and what does
that mean that the data is being
transposed when we actually
input so we'll go a little bit deeper to
understand
how the different aspects of linkage and
distance
can help us understand what do we
actually mean
when we deal with data right because
this is not going to be
distance in a three-dimensional space
between
objects this is going to be distance in
a multi-dimensional space in a matrix
and so all of these different methods of
evaluating
linkages and distances will play a role
in what we ultimately get as a result so
when we
analyze our results we'll actually look
at visual representation
and link how the different settings that
we put
into the method give us different types
of outputs
we'll also see the relationship between
visualization of one type of data
and visualization of the same data in
terms of
how much information it provides because
the objective of the analysis
and matching analysis visualization
is to really provide us insights into
in-depth
biological and biomedical problems for
example
we'll take a look at the cancer genome
atlas
that provides us multi-omics data sets
about a variety of different
types of cancers where we can start
realizing
what are the important factors about
tissue specialization
as well as cancer processes that we
would like to study
using some of these analytical tools now
from a data science perspective
we'll also see how some of these
different types of methods
are applicable not only for a output
that gives us a new group or an idea
about what the data structure is it is
also a very useful tool
for data visualization so we'll see how
some of these examples
really are great examples to improve our
visualization techniques
and to interpret the data that we have
in a much better way
now after we talk about dimensionality
reduction in clustering
we'll talk about classification machine
learning
is typically referred to two types of
problems
classification or prediction of a
specific class
based on label data as well as
regression
and so regression is a prediction of
your next
output from a continuous data set and we
won't as much
focus on regression but we will focus on
classification so in classification we
will talk about
two specific sub sets or sub problems
which is prediction itself and feature
supervised machine learning is a process
when we
take source data and are able to label
that data
to prepare a training data set which is
then used
to train an algorithm or a machine a
computer
to be able to predict what it
learned from the training data set on
some test data
now the magic of making the training
data set representative of a problem
that we're actually interested in
and then having the right set of test
and validation data
is critical to making sure that your
model is going to be effective
and is going to be able to adapt to
unexpected types of challenges that it
will face
in the real world so we'll call it a
black box for now
but this black box has a name and each
one of these algorithms that we put in
the black box
will approach the problem a little bit
differently so when we are able to
offer a number of different examples a
number of different
project data sets that have real world
implications about treatment about
diagnostics
about selecting a specific type of an
approach to treat a patient
we will see how these different
algorithms actually work
and so when we look at the output and
we're able to
understand the output that this
algorithm provides us with
we'll also be able to evaluate both the
accuracy
and the feature significance of our data
set
so these are very useful tools that
in the context of machine learning
provide us with an additional
insight into how we can start working
with the data sets
these different types of methods are
organized by different types of decision
trees
discriminate analyses or support vector
machines and so we'll take an example
this will not be a comprehensive
overview of
all of the possible methods out there
but i think it will provide you with a
real clear understanding
of how different categories of methods
actually work
and what are some of the important
parameters for us to tune
when we try to apply these data sets to
a specific
problem for example we'll talk about
random forest and we'll talk about the
problem of
bagging and applying multiple decision
trees
to get a good prediction consistently
and also do feature selection as we go
through that process
we'll talk about how we can take support
vector machines
and modify the way that the support
vector machines deals with classes
also to give us an understanding of how
it can be applied to
different types of kernel problems
different types of
complex classes and also feature
selection
in the context of support vector
machines so let me briefly explain
what you will do after you learn about
the conceptual part of the program
and are able to apply some of these data
sets so some of these methods
to a real data set
so when i talk about this code platform
i am talking about a specific
number of tools that we have designed
to support your learning process so
first when you get to
start the program you will actually
register
on the platform register for the program
so let me show you briefly what i mean
on the platform as i mentioned before
there's a variety of different resources
starting from
a synchronous coursework to the set
to the sessions that we will have as an
interactive session and once you join
this program
and register for membership you will
have access
to all of these upcoming sessions in
each one of these sessions we will
introduce
a particular topic and you will be able
to ask
questions and get support through the
forum that is monitored daily
and where we can provide you with
additional information about all of
these different methods and data sets
that we are covering
you will also get access to coursework
in the coursework you will get
much more in-depth explanation of the
different topics that we cover in the
program
and have practical project examples that
you can practice on
you will be able to monitor your own
progress
by looking at what you have completed
where you have left off
and tracking the points that you get as
a result of each one of your activity
you will also get personal feedback on
the assignments that you submit
inside the courses there are assignments
that you will complete
and those assignments will be actually
evaluated by a person who will provide
you with comments
with additional links to resources that
you can study
or coursework that you can review to
make sure that the concept is clear
now some of these concepts are going to
be based
on coding and some of these are going to
be based
on an interactive platform that you can
actually use
without any coding right so we'll kind
of go from a high level overview
more and more in-depth and more and more
technical and depending on how technical
you want to get you can actually get
pretty far
by downloading eventually the scripts
onto your own system
and working directly in python or r
to make sure that you understand how all
that we do on the platform and we do in
the coding exercises
could be carried on without these tools
now an important part of these data sets
is that they are huge
when we're talking about transcriptomic
or genomic data literally
every sample has over gigabytes of data
when you talk about such data having a
coding environment
is not enough you have to have a lot of
ram you have to have a lot of cpu power
so what we are trying to do is to level
the field for anyone
that does not know coding that does not
have those kinds of resources
to still be able to actually do real
research
so when you get access to the platform
you will be able to use
first demo pipelines that do not require
any kind of inputs and outputs but just
really
require for you to understand the logic
of the analysis
and once you understand the logic of the
analysis you can see the output
immediately without waiting for anything
to happen at all
for example in in this case we are
looking
at output of a genomic
visualization pipeline where we can see
how individual reads from a particular
data set
are aligned to a reference genome right
and we can explore our data
at the read level in another example
when we want to do a event an estimation
of gene expression we can actually build
a combination of
other types of tools and those tools
will allow us to study
how high or low each gene
is expressed and as you can see
when you go through this process you
actually get to understand
what each step does and quickly get
an output and we will talk about these
outputs
and we'll talk about the different
biomedical challenges that these
problems
are illustrating how the bioinformatics
methods or pipelines
apply to this data set help us
understand what is
in these outputs now at the next level
you will be able to go to the platform
and actually create these analyses
yourself on a project of your own
now you will have to make some decisions
about what type of data you're putting
in
and how will that data be processed
using the same tools that you've learned
about
in the coursework and in the demo
pipelines
after you run some of these you will see
that
some of the results will actually
include
outputs as downloadable code
so here for example i will look
at an example pipeline that i ran and
you can see that one of the outputs
is a pack in r i can take this package
in
r and actually play around with the same
code
understanding what it does in these
exercises or tutorials
and then playing around with them again
using
a cloud environment so we are offering
two
options on this cloud tutorial space
the first option is guided coding
tutorials
so let's take a look at an example here
we took the same code that was in the
output from the pipeline
and we are taking a gene expression data
set
to understand what can this gene
expression data set
tell us about the problem that we are
studying
once we understand it we go through a
breakdown of the code we understand what
libraries are used
what how do we input the data what do we
actually do
to plot the data and to perform the
analysis
after that you get to try it yourself
you actually can change the input data
set
you can change the parameters and you
can run this data set
to understand what will actually produce
this runs on our server so when it runs
on our server
you will see an output provided to you
just on the browser by running on the
server so for example here
i got the same results from this
principal component analysis
in a 3d view in python however
we do not offer a server to
run your analysis in python when you
select the same
exercise in python you will be able to
actually
run this on your own computer now you'll
see the differences in code and
understand how it relates to solving the
same type of a challenge but in a
different coding language
but you will actually have to load all
of the information
in your browser so the next step
after you have completed your coding
challenge
you can download the full code and you
can actually go
into your own environment and start
playing around
with that code to make sure that you
understand how to set
your working environment your data sets
from your computer and make the output
save
into files now there are additional
benefits to that because you can
actually call
specific functions that can only work on
your computer
and not on the server that we provide
you so we hope that this process
is going to be effective for all of you
to go from
a high level overview of what we are
doing
in terms of the logic of analysis to see
the different
examples of projects to them to be able
to be further
into the code itself and eventually set
it up
on your computer so let me tell you
what are some of the coding exercises
that we have prepared
for this program so we will talk about
different tools like differential gene
expression which really uses statistical
analysis
as well as some clustering to make
effective visualization
of differentially expressed genes we'll
talk about
principal component analysis as a
dimensionality reduction
analysis for these complex data sets
like
gene expression we'll talk about
clustering and different types of
clustering like k-means or hierarchical
clustering
and we'll also talk about classification
the problem where we have to assign
classes to our data sets and then see
what types of methods
are giving us the best prediction also
evaluating
what is this prediction quality how
accurate is it
and how stable it is when we apply it to
a different
validation data set
finally we'll talk about a variety of
different applications so i think what's
fascinating
in terms of data science for biomedical
data
is that you can quickly see
the application of these tools to very
important and significant data sets
these are not data sets that
are about generating money these are not
data sets that are about
social sentiment and interaction between
people
these are data sets that really explain
the basis of diseases different
biological processes
at the subcellular level and infection
using examples from pathogens that we're
all
painfully aware of like covet 19. so we
really
put a lot of effort into preparing
project examples
curated data sets and specific guidance
to give you
a background before you jump into your
analysis
if you've seen like me any other types
of
examples on data science and machine
learning you know that in each
presentation at least
30 minutes is dedicated to explaining a
data set and unfortunately we get to use
very simple data sets data sets that are
actually
about value of homes or square footage
or pedals and and different types of
plants so
i think it's very important for us to
here understand
what types of challenges we're going to
be solving
so one example that we'll be using is
the application of machine learning
for prediction of survival for cancer
patients
over a time frame of about five to ten
years
so this is a huge challenge when you
look at a patient today
how can you actually predict will that
patient survive
will it have a recurrence of the same
disease what are their risk
level what are their chances of survival
and we'll talk
about specific ways that we can use this
type of
information to make decisions about
treatment selection
we'll also talk about a novel type of
cancer therapy drugs
and these drugs have started to become
more and more popular because of their
effectiveness starting from a drug
called herceptin that was introduced in
the 1990s
so not so long ago and we'll talk about
the relationship
between the biological understanding of
how
these different diseases occur develop
and manifest in different patients
and what are the specific types of
indications that we can extract from big
data
that allow us to target those specific
pathways
we'll also talk about the application of
big data right so once we have a
collection of big data
how is that actually changing our
ability to
analyze a new patient that comes in
providing a much more accurate diagnosis
by assigning that patient to a
particular
class or group that we have already
previously studied
so we'll actually talk about a number of
different examples like i mentioned
before
these examples are both in the clinical
domain
and in the pharma and biotechnology
domain
so in the clinical domain we'll talk
about examples of patient stratification
how we can group patients by risk
and what do we actually call risk how do
we know what their risk is
disease classification and diagnostic so
how do we know
what a disease is and how do these
machine learning tools actually change
our understanding of disease
and how they actually affect today our
ability to diagnose diseases like cancer
or like individual types of infections
infections that have resistance to
specific treatments or
infections that are caused by different
pathogens
they are also applied to identification
of potential responders to therapy so we
can actually
study a patient today and predict what
is the most likely course of treatment
or
combinations of treatments or what kinds
of interactions we should be aware of
to make sure that the treatment or the
therapy is effective
obviously in the basic research domain
the mechanisms of disease onset and
progression are critical because
ultimately
the machine learning model that we
designed has to be
easy to explain to someone that needs to
trust that machine learning model so a
big challenge with machine learning
is when the machine learning model
predicts something very obvious
if you tell a patient that they should
be taking this drug or another
you just have to say that you're a
doctor for that patient to trust you
somewhat but if you're talking to
doctors that have
years of experience and know that this
drug
and that drug have a similar mechanism
of action or they perform a similar
function when they metabolize
you actually have to convince them that
the machine learning prediction
that this drug should be used instead of
a drug that they're familiar with
you actually have to be able to explain
the model performance
and what features it actually is based
on
so that part of it is very critical for
machine learning adoption in the
clinical world
in farmland biotechnology as you all
know it takes
over seven years to bring a drug to
market so there are critical challenges
to making sure
that the new drugs that are discovered
using
accumulated data from thousands of
patients in a variety of conditions
are actually going to be effective and
they're going to be
used effectively when they are on the
market so to say
so there's a variety of challenges like
biomarker discovery
how do we understand based on molecular
features
which patients to treat with what drug
detection of toxicity at the in vitro
stage so before we start testing this
in humans how do we actually understand
that a drug
will not be toxic right how do we
eliminate the potential
of long-term toxicity for example side
effects that are related to
chronic heart conditions when we are
trying to
you know treat mild conditions uh like
inflammation in joints or something like
this right so how do we detect that at
an early stage
analysis of molecular mechanisms of a
drug action or target discovery
and also drug repurposing or
repositioning how do we actually
apply these tools to solve challenges
when we talk about known approved drugs
that
are known and studied potentially to
have
new indications or new applications to
new types of treatments
so i think very very important and very
practical applications that we can
try and apply these methods to now i
think the exciting part of it
is to actually try and apply the methods
that you will learn in this program
two data sets where you kind of know
what the outcome would be
at first right so at first you can
really see
the outputs from your own analysis
and compare them to analysis that an
expert team
has done and once you know how that
matches up you can actually start
applying
those to new types of questions so a
particular
objective for these programs for us is
to be able to
uh allow you to develop a new project
idea and we have a set of guidelines
that we have prepared that we think will
help you in that journey
so in fact i think that in bibs maybe
you can share this link also for the
participants
we have a guide on how to prepare your
own project so
as we talk about tools and the different
applications and the different example
data sets
how do you actually start developing
your own project
so again this project or this program
will consist of two weeks and in those
two weeks we will cover
a lot of ground to get you into this
domain of big data and
different types of tools to process
analyze visualize and interpret the data
sets
after the two weeks are over you will
have additional time
to work with our support on an
independent project
or on working on one of the projects
that we have prepared as an example
for you to learn from now i
want to conclude this with uh
some registration links that you can use
to complete your registration if you're
interested in this program
we have a process where you first
fill out a pre-registration link
and please put these links on
the chat if possible so
the pre-registration link and let me
actually go to this link
will get you to a page where you learn
about the program topics
you can also ask us questions obviously
in the session
after i complete we'll have some time
about five minutes
to come to answer any questions you
might have
and once you fill out this information
you send it to us and our team
actually reviews reviews this
information
and sends you some additional
information on what to do if you would
like to register
who is this for and what is the best way
for you to use this program right so we
want to make sure that it's very clear
this program is designed specifically
for those that are
interested in big data is specifically
in omics data
applied to biomedical domain and
would like to go beyond kind of an
interactive high level bioinformatics
so they would like to get some coding
experience
as a result of this but it is not a
coding
workshop this is not a program to get
you to be proficient in r
or python we hope that you are either
already familiar with one of these
languages
or are committed enough to independently
pursue
additional help with getting proficient
in those languages we will simply not
have enough time
to do that in this program so but you
will get some experience
you will get an understanding of the
different methods and you'll be able to
interact with our team
to get help if you decide to go deeper
into one of these topics
okay so after you do this you actually
go
to you receive a link to complete your
registration
on the main program page now once you
complete this registration
you create a profile for yourself this
profile
is where you start accumulating points
so i'll explain what this means
uh you can see here an example profile
of one of our participants you can see
that once they register and by the way
the registration itself is free and we
also have some free tools available for
you
you will see that a person who has
registered will have to
create a profile where all of their
activity is accessible
so that we can track and address any
issues that come up
you will have a point system that helps
you estimate
how far along you are in this process of
learning
and you can also continue picking up
from different courses that you have
started before
continuing to make progress in this
course in those courses and completing
those
now each independent course is
either included in the program or
accessible for free
or some of the courses might not be a
part of this program so you'll have to
see which courses are actually
accessible to you in the program
and once you complete them you get
individual certificates for completing
those courses
and they will also be available right
here under your profile
after you do that you can continue to
go deeper into one of the projects that
we make accessible
so those projects will illustrate some
of those applications that i've already
covered
so that program is going to give you
a personal profile that personal profile
helps you start building some of that
points
some of those points and eventually the
top participants
are actually highlighted on our
leaderboard and so when we highlight
those participants on the leaderboard
we also tell their story we also explain
the projects that they have done
and i believe vip say you have a link to
some of those projects that have
previously been done by some of our
participants
you know we're very encouraged and proud
to have received you know a lot of
very high quality feedback for these
programs
and so we think that you know if the
fit is right for you and you are ready
to commit the time
and you know the resources in terms of
uh how much effort you will have to put
in to actually make the most out of
these programs
you can get a lot from these different
programs
so i'm going to um pause now
and i'm just going to make this open for
any questions that you might have
uh i'm going to um you know ask biepsa
and mohit to
let me know if there are any questions
also on youtube
and i'll be able to continue in
addressing those questions
in the future
thank you india uh i think we have
addressed the questions on
youtube already so i would like to ask
if
anyone has a question now we can we can
address those as well
okay and also i have a few questions
here
um that are unfortunately just on
um on zoom
okay so so there's a question i'm a
beginner with
no prior knowledge of data science still
i am able to understand it
but it would be better if you can
explain some technical terms for
beginners
yeah so that would be the exact
objective of this program
is to provide you with an overview of
both the high level logic and the
specific
terms that are commonly used we'll use
that both as a general session
explanation of what these terms are but
also we'll see an example
um so so let me actually um
show you an example um
in a publication right so one of the
objectives for this is for you to then
be able to read a publication and really
understand what they mean so here you
can see
how we used least square support vector
machines and random forest algorithms to
identify molecular features associated
with responses of a collection of 70
breast cancer cell lines
to 90 experimental or approved
therapeutic agents
so you can see how right here in the
abstract which is just a few sentences
long
you already have to know what is least
square support vector machines what is
random forest algorithm
what are molecular features what how do
we find
or establish association how do we
measure responses
what are these breast cancer cell lines
right so a lot of questions so we will
go into detail about
each one of these terms
okay so how much coding do you need to
know
uh the coding that you can start with
zero coding experience literally if you
have zero coding experience and you
start
you will quickly understand how some of
the methods
are done using coding now you can also
see
as a result of this program what type of
languages are
there and what kinds of
languages are best for what type of
application and what are some of the
considerations right so hopefully if you
don't know any coding
you'll be able to decide whether you
want to pursue
more specialized training in r or in
python
right or you want to just do a little
bit of both
right so that are is one of the outcomes
that we hope
to achieve from this program how long
live sessions the live sessions are
going to be one and a half hours long
so they will include an overview of a
topic
a practical exercise that we will go
through together make sure that you're
able to do that exercise
and then have some time for discussion
so if you have any questions
we're able to address those
okay professor babu you're in vivo
pharmacologist interest to take up the
course but i have knowledge
on statistics but beginner for data
science and no knowledge on coding or
computer program
i think that's a perfect program for you
because it does require for you to kind
of understand
logically what's going on but then with
the computer programming or coding
you will get guided um you know
tutorials
at first then you will download them on
your computer will actually provide you
with some tools where you can start
practicing
so for software really will guide you
and maybe i'll give you an example here
if you go well eventually once you're
registered
you'll see here a clear
explanation of r and python
and how to set it up on your computer so
it's a real
interactive tutorial that you can go
through and if you have any questions
about this
you'll really see um what we
i mean will will help you kind of
install all of this and and
basically you the only things that you
will need is to install
r and python on your computer um our
studio is preferable just to give you a
an environment to work with and then
we'll go through some of these
in in here which is an online platform
you don't need
anything to to run these examples
and we'll go from very basic on how to
load
uh you know manipulate and visualize
uh your data and it's going to start
with very simple
exercises okay so hopefully i answered
that question
what special alterations apps um so
again not really any apps um all you
would need
is um r r studio
and uh python to be installed on your
computer
okay great well thank you for attending
today
um hopefully uh biebs and mohit if you
could
post some of those links again for those
that are interested to review
some of the benefits of the program
again i think the program
is unique in the sense of online courses
it is not a typical
udemy or coursera course where you just
watch videos
and then do something on your own and
hope to get some feedback
this is a very guided program
and this program is going to be you know
really
focused on the outcome so it is actually
in our interest
to get you to a place where you can
demonstrate your profile and the
projects
that you have prepared um
as a real validation of
what you have learned right so you can
see some of the examples here and some
of the feedback from real participants
we also have a page on some of the
project
outcomes um if you have some of those
links we have a number of recent
projects that people have prepared
in our past programs and we run these
programs all the time
so there's really a variety of topics
that come up
in different in different programs
that we conduct
okay so thank you again for joining this
webinar
we are going to be continuing to
reach out to you with these links by
email so that you have them
after this webinar is over and we
welcome all of you to join
come monday on august 3rd so we still
have a few days for
any one of you that is interested to
complete your registration
please reach out to marketing at
pine.bio
if you have any additional questions
about the registration process
thank you for joining and we'll see you
again soon